Speaker 1: All right, let's get into this week's
mailbag. I got a weird email from someone last
week saying I should call this my apple bag, which
is just strange. I think it relates to that weird
Nicki Minaj story, and I talked about apple bags,
but I don't think Apple Bags is an appropriate
name for this segment. This is the mailbag. You
can participate maybe if your email is interesting
and smart enough or crazy enough, right? There's
two types by emailing info at David Pakman VK.com.
This has been an increasingly popular segment.
Emails are just dumping in people wanting their
questions answered. Let's just get right
into it. Folks, please. Starting with Brian,
Brian wrote. I don't even care that Brian
spelled my name wrong. He says, Mr. Pacman,
I enjoy your show. I have heard you comment
a few times about Donald Trump misstating the
1918 Spanish flu by repeating 1917 Spanish flu.
He is not getting this wrong on accident. 17 is
a Q and on reference or Conan, as some say or
shout out, every time he uses 17 incorrectly,
it is done purposefully. Thank you for what you
do. Yeah, we had a caller last week on live calls
who said the same thing, which is Q, is the
17th letter of the alphabet, right? So Ms 13 and
14 15 P16 Q 17, that part checks out. Maybe that's
true. I've now heard this from a few people.
Maybe, yeah, I don't know, and if that's the
case, it would be really disturbing about what
it says about former President Trump that
he is sort of surreptitiously signaling
to the QAnon conspiracy theories. I would put
nothing past Trump whatsoever. Part of me wonders
whether he's clever or smart enough to even do
that. Maybe somebody gave him the idea. I think
the most likely explanation is also the simplest
one Trump misstated the 1918 flu is the 1917 flu
once. Nobody corrected him or they did. But Trump
is too much of a narcissist to change it because
it would concede that he said something wrong.
So he's just continuing to call it the 1917 flu.
That's my sort of guess. Next, the email is from a
way. No way, no, says Sir. How does YouTube's ban
on misinformation affect Joe Rogan? It's
a good question. I think you're referring
to YouTube banning all anti-vax stuff. It's
pretty clear to me that Joe Rogan is staying
on this side of the YouTube rules. Some of
his guests may be on their own. Channels
are going past that line, but my instinct in
looking at the updated rules. And remember that
the updated rules from YouTube about they've
banned anti-vaxxers and anti-vax content.
It it was already in place for COVID vaccine
stuff. They've just expanded it to be all anti-vax
stuff. And so since the controversial subject
matter on Rogan's channel has been about when
it comes to vaccines, the COVID vaccine. That ban
was already in place, so I don't actually think
that the new rules will really affect Rogan. A lot
of people may not know this, but there's much more
content demonetized on YouTube than there is
removed. There's actually, I mean, of course,
like straight up gore and violence and out and
out conspiracy anti-vax stuff. It's removed. The
vast majority of content is just demonetized when
it violates terms and conditions. So my belief is
Joe Rogan is not going to be affected by this
in any way. Next email today is from Daniel.
Daniel says evidence the Pentagon has gave way
more money to the Wuhan lab, then Dr. Fauci's NIH,
and the fact that Peter Daszak is the main one
who gave all that money to the Wuhan scientists
directly and how one seems to care. I think
what Daniel is trying to say is that despite
what he believes to be evidence about money going
from the NIH to the Wuhan lab, that no one seems
to care. I believe that that's what this email
is about. Listen, I've weighed in on this before.
My view is I want to know the truth about the
world period. I am not. This is not a show where
either for posturing or for narrative crafting
or for any reason, I exclude things from the
show that I believe are important or lie to the
audience in any way. I always give my opinion.
I want to know the truth about the Wuhan lab
and funding and Dr. Fauci and the entire thing.
I think what's important is that we understand,
first of all, how much of this entire Dr. Fauci
controversy fundamentally comes down to semantics,
which I talked about last week on the Friday show
with a caller who called in. That's number one and
number two. There is a lot of misinformation about
this issue. So I continue to look when things come
across my desk or my screen, as it might better be
said into the new Wuhan issue. And if I have some
kind of major thing to come to you with and say,
Sirs and M&Ms, here's some news. You can rest
assured that I will do that. Let's go to the
next email. This is very weaponized. Now, I should
actually even take it off the screen for a second.
If there are kids in the room, get them out. If
you have dogs that are particularly sensitive
to cringe. Get them out, cats. They don't give a
damn what the hell is on the screen. But in all
seriousness, this is very, very weaponized.
William wrote to me and said they all died.
David, I am the only member of my family and
friend group who was smart enough to not listen
to celebrity propaganda. And unfortunately, I was
right. Almost everyone I know personally has died
from a vaccine. My mother and I are the
only ones left. She took the vaccine,
but thankfully her immune system kicked it out.
That's actually it. So it's so crazy. It's funny.
What am I supposed to do now that everybody I know
and love is dead because of your stupid vaccine?
Does this even deserve a reply? Like, I don't even
I'm not even, you know, this is either someone,
I mean, like, what? What is this, right? OK,
so it could be just someone who's trolling.
Fine. Let's imagine it's not. This could be
someone whose family really has tragically died
from different issues, could be even covered, and
they are wrongly blaming it on being vaccinated.
Also, they say, from a vaccine, not
necessarily even COVID. So it could be
someone who is mis attributing death to vaccines.
Could be someone who's completely delusional and
disconnected from the real world. I don't know.
Could could be a serial murderer who has killed
people and is saying it was vaccine. This could
be anything other than what it purports to be. I
think that that's sort of where I would leave it.
But these folks are out there. Anthony wrote to me
and said misleading characterization. Mr.
Pacman, it is often stated in the media
that most Republicans believe Trump won the
2020 election. Wouldn't it be more accurate
to say that most Republicans claim they believe
Trump won the election? Big difference? No,
this is a beautiful question. We talked about
this before, and we talked about this in a segment
where I talked about the kind of magical thinking
and we're at war mentality of many of these
Trump supporters where we wondered when they say,
we believe Trump won. Do they really believe it?
Or is it the way they are choosing to answer
polls in order to be part of the right team
and in order to perpetuate some more general idea
that they don't like Joe Biden? They don't like
that Joe Biden won. And I think that I know I've
been citing this a lot lately, but Neil Postman
in Technopolis has a very good couple of pages
about exactly this issue, about opinion polling,
which is opinion polling. We opinion polling
becomes an invisible technology in the sense
that we just look at the results of the poll and
we don't think about why was it done? Who did it?
What does it really mean to answer questions in
one way or the other? And how were the questions
asked? And what a poll tells us is an opinion
poll tells us what people claim to believe,
and people might claim to believe something they
don't believe for different reasons. We talked,
you know, there was this idea that the the polls
leading into 2020 that said Joe Biden was winning
were wrong because the wrong people were being
polled right sampling problem. Or there were
people up bashful Trump supporters not willing
to say that they supported Trump, but they really
did. It ended up basically being false. I mean,
Wisconsin was off, there's no doubt about it,
but it basically was not true. But when it comes
to what people believe about the 2020 election,
it's important to say that the polls tell us what
people claim to believe, and they may not actually
believe the things they claim to believe for a
whole bunch of different reasons. Very good point.
A next email is from Larry Larry says,
Keep drinking the now. It gets crazy now,
by the way. Keep drinking the Kool-Aid. Biden
is the worst president in my lifetime a liar,
a wife stealer, and he has been selling out our
country for his family's benefit for decades.
It sounds like Larry's describing Trump. Quite
frankly, Larry goes on to say Trader Joe's
where everything is for sale. Big Fart. Here we
go with this stuff. Big Pharma must also love you.
They are also a criminal organization. And have
you convinced hook, line and sinker that they
are our savior? Open your eyes, young man. So
the first part is just whacked. I mean, like,
hard whacked the last part. You know, a bunch of
people have written in and they've said, David,
clearly you're being paid to promote vaccines.
And I tweeted about this earlier in the week.
Why would anyone pay me to promote, like, first of
all, promote a report on the science of vaccines?
But why would anyone pay me to promote vaccines?
Were it were small potatoes, right? Like in the
grand scheme of things, it would be sort
of a dumb thing to do. And in addition,
why would they pay me given that I've reported
on the science of vaccines for a long time,
like they don't? What else can I really say about
vaccines other than reporting when they work and
what the impact of those vaccinations is? And
this is part of the sort of superstructure around
vaccination disinformation that's out there, which
is that some of the people there's lies being told
it's all lies is the point. There's lies being
told about how safe the vaccine is. That's the
people who email in. And they say thousands, tens
of thousands, hundreds of thousands of people died
from the vaccine. That's one part. But then also
the people telling you what they claim is the
science of vaccines. Those people have been paid,
so they simply can't be believed. It looks like
they're giving you science, but they're giving
you stuff they've been given by someone that paid
them. And the whole point of it is not to just
accept reality and live it in this other world,
which is preferable to them. It's a preferable
world to them. It's simpler. And that's the appeal
of some conspiracy theories. A lot of people.
Find it hard to accept. That bad things happen,
unpredictable things happen every hundred
years or so, we get a 100 year pandemic,
but we've got a vaccine that helps. That
sounds out of control to a lot of people.
It's more appealing to believe
this was all just done by humans.
That's where you get the vaccine. I'm sorry.
The virus was created in a bioweapons lab and
released because that's control. It's not a random
event, it's not a probabilistic event anymore, and
the vaccine is also part of the exact same
plot. It's all a plot for some people,
even though they claim to be outraged by it. They
would rather live in a world where everything is
controlled by man rather than than things
that can happen, that are left to chance,
unpredictable bad things that's at the root of
much conspiracy ism. OK, last one today. Here's
a bonus. This one came in via Facebook on Monday
morning. This is from George. This is really wild,
George says. You keep calling Trump supporters
delusional. I truly hope that you open your eyes
before the Communist Democrat Nazi Party.
Come for you. Few contradictions there.
Trump did not lose the 2020 election. It was
part of a Cullors revolution cullors. Revolution,
educate yourself, educate your followers and
open your eyes, otherwise you might just find
your. You might find yourself on that train, just
like the Jews found themselves on a Nazi train.
Except this time it won't be gas. It'll be an
injection. They call it a vaccine. Dumb ass.
Folks, folks, this is what we're up against.
We're going to have to try to solve the problems
of humanity despite people like this. I
don't see any way to get them to help us.
Maybe we can prevent them from hurting us.
Maybe. But it is not looking very good.
Not looking very good. Get your emails
in for next week's mailbag info at David
Pakman dot com. We have a fantastic bonus
show today. It's all meet today on the
bonus show. I know many people expecting
only producer pat today. It's all me.
Speaker 4: I will see you
Unidentified: on the bonus, Kevin.